we've
never done a uh uh uh ever
we've never done a organization
recruiting the staffing agency
recruiting for the field
we've always rule use recruiting
agencies for home office
always yep multiple staff and for home
office
never for the field that's been 100 war
market
and that's worked very very well for us
now obviously
you have to also know that we get a lot
of leads that come through
uh php's youtube channel uh or people
see a video from me on
valuetainment and then they say what
does this guy do oh my gosh i've always
wanted to get into insurance and then
boom
they send an information and that goes
out and somehow some way they get
involved
but we don't have a place we go through
where we get the leads we just have a
ridiculous system
now we've trained our guys on a warm
market that's worked very well
and if you do that right it could work
very well for you a lot of people use
leads
we don't today if you're looking at
young guys i mean instagram today is the
number one recruiting tool out there
hands down there's not a better tool in
recruiting today than instagram
it's specifically for sales guys and
girls
so but but the part you got to be
thinking about is the following let me
flip it on you a little bit
the com structure of many companies
will determine whether the sales people
will recruit
or they will sell where you put your
incentives
is where your sales people will go bring
new talent for you
so if a part of your incentive is pre
based on
me recruiting talent i'm going to
recruit more talent for you i was
consulting this uh uh
uh trucking company and they were doing
you know
five million a year you know 10 million
a year business
and i went out there one day and we
worked on their comp plan for an entire
day we spent one full day on their comp
plan
one full day under complex and we came
back
and we put a comp structure together for
them
2020 they ended up with a quarter of a
billion dollars of sales but they
but their sales ins all and all they
changed is they changed the incentive
for their branch managers that they had
and they started bringing in guys that
started selling loads and the next thing
you know now they have branches in
us mexico canada europe armenia all over
the place
and they're doing around a quarter of a
billion dollars a year you got to kind
of look at your comp plan and see where
the incentive could be for your sales
guys to be recruiting
versus just selling if you look at if
you look at a guy's kids
on how the kid does whatever he does
look at kids of teachers you guys ever
noticed kids of teachers
if you know a teacher in your family
that's a older teacher like let's just
say in their 60s
and they have three or four kids what do
their kids do
how many of your kids got a four year
degree why
because the teacher's number one
incentive in the family is to do what
get good grades
now you look at an entrepreneur's kids
what's the incentives
it's a very different incentive system
so whatever incentive you create
i guarantee your kids are going to go
after those incentives
your sales guys are going to go through
those incentives so
test your incentive system i changed my
comp structure probably 50 times in the
first 24 months finally i hit a sweet
spot and then i just said oh my gosh
this one's gonna take off
and then it took off i just had a
meeting with my guys and i announced to
them
on the first my announcement was uh
top 30 performers in a company
for 21st to 30th place i'm getting
everybody a cash corvette c8
i buy for them uh uh 11th
through the 20th i get them a porsche
911 and i fly them out to uh
germany to go pick out the porsche
second to tenth place i'm getting
everybody a cash brand new ferrari
portofino
and then first place i'm getting you
cash aventador and i'm flying you out to
lamborghini headquarters to get this for
you right okay now watch this in
order for me to buy those five million
dollars worth of cars
the company has to grow forty percent if
we grow forty percent
five million is nothing to me you you
know what i'm saying like fine
first i'll spend a five million bucks
and you have no idea how crazy people
are going right now
guys if we do this i'm going to do this
if we do this i'm going to do this so
there's a relationship
where one of the most important
trainings i ever did for my before my
company is the following
i said let's talk about here's how it
opened up
and this is something all of you guys
can do
i said it was a four-hour session i had
with my guys i sat them in my room
in woodland hills and i said guys um
i want you here long term and i want you
to give your best
but before i give you that what is your
expectation of me
what do you expect from me as a ceo and
at first they start very
soft like small stuff well you know
uh we would like this from you okay
great
we would like that we would like you to
be responsible financially okay great
we were like this or we would like you
to add millions in the comp one day we
would like you to
we will look okay so they said we would
like you we would like you we would like
you we would like to
and then it got bigger which was great
because it set me up for what
i said perfect in order for me to be
able to give this from you is it fair to
say that i should have some expectations
of you as well
yes i said i got a powerpoint prepared
of what i expect from you in order for
you to get what you get
and this can be a very simple
relationship together let me go through
it with you
boom boom boom two-hour powerpoint i
went through on exactly what i expected
from now
so then everybody understood you want
this let's do this
you want this let's do this you want
that's what helped us grow and i think
sometimes the relationship between the
supervisor the ceo the boss and their
people
it's not like that so you screw it up
but if you come from a
and you have to let them talk first not
you so you just got a sneak little pig
from an episode that i did in this video
if you want to see the full episode
click over here to watch the entire
episode and if you've not subscribed
to this channel please do so take care
everybody
you